well joining me now is a former BBC
Royal correspondent Michael Cole talk to
the presenter Richard Tice and BBC
broadcast and Sunday Times columnist
Matthew said all of whom are shared by
one thing they all completely disagree
with me so this is a unique playing
field where it's basically me up against
a team who's going to try and take me
down and I'm going to be curious as to
which one of them might be to persuade
it Michael let me start with you you're
a BBC man to your bootstrap you worked
there several decades
20 years right I so what do you what do
you think of this from a BBC perspective
I think that he has to be severely
reprimanded and I think the BBC needs to
seriously review his contract why
because he is the face of the BBC in a
very real way in exactly the same way
that when we were growing up Richard
dimbleby was also I'm sorry no dimbleby
was the face of BBC News very different
thing he was lilica has nothing to do
with the news division he's not even a
BBC employee no Richard dimbleby was he
was in fact that Panorama was current
affairs it wasn't news Well news anchor
and Affairs yes but the bigger the point
is this
BBC sport is not Speaker's Corner we're
not waiting for a program called rant of
the day literally every Saturday night a
match of the day rent and express
strongly held opinions is literally the
speakers match of the day on sport yes
on sport so what's the difference what
the difference is that when you have the
responsibility
of that position getting 1.35 million
pounds of the tech of the license payers
money every year actually cheat you for
what he does well maybe I think so see
well only because in the marketplace if
Gary lineke was available to anybody he
would earn a lot more money and actually
earns more money pro-rata for other
companies than just for the BBC well
indeed he works for them there now I'm
quite sure he would have no difficulty
at all finding other employment
he would have the pleasure of being a
martyr and I'm quite sure he's one of
the best sports presenters in the world
he shouldn't be begrudged for the money
he earns Tim Davey is the fairly new
director general of the BBC and he said
very clearly at the outset that he
wanted to instill and insist upon
impartiality impartiality is the BBC's
unique calling card so that is what's
wrong trust around the world so can a
sports presenter and a face a sport like
Gary deniker Express a political opinion
yes if he wants to stand for Parliament
or
so here's my follow-up when Gary lineker
launched this year's World Cup last
year's World Cup in Qatar wrong two he
did a two-minute monologue yes attacking
the humans rights record of the host
nation Qatar he was told to do that by
BBC management so BBC management decided
then that garudanika could be overtly
political in his opinions I think on the
BBC they were on the BBC at their
request I'm coming to you on the BBC
Michael yes that's right they were
covering their backs because they've
been so much about it in the paper they
said how could they have the bra snakes
turn around having ordered him to do
that and express a political opinion on
their main show of the year the World
Cup launch show how could they do that
and then turn around and say you can't
express regular people that's the matter
for BBC sport when you're when you're
watching a sports Personality you do not
expect a political opinions now Lord
Lord grade Michael grade who was 80
years say by the way he was a great man
happy birthday one he when he was head
of Channel 4 he said the BBC is there to
keep the rest of us straight in other
words to set the standard and that
standard means impartiality on all the
important matters and that's it's a
unique calling Clinic is not even
impartial about football well he just
saw him in his underpants have he made a
bet on BBC about Leicester winning the
Premier League
the bottom line so come on you're the
politician yes and by the way you
profess to be the great standard bearer
of freezer he's not denying him his
right to his freeze do you want him
fight wear it conflicts do you want him
fired we're at conflicts peers is he's
in breach of the BBC code of conduct
he's not he is he's absolutely I've got
it here it's unusual for you not to know
this I know the code of content right he
is in breach he's not allowed according
to this in any circumstances whether in
journalism or Finance anything you post
on social media from a personal or a BBC
account he's in breach of that no he's
in breach that applies to news no no and
this is an impossible that applies to
news and current
I spoke to Gary this morning it is not
in his contract which may explain why
the BBC has been incapable so far of of
doing any disciplinary action he is a
freelance contractor that's irrelevance
nothing in his contract about his tweets
he represents the BBC everybody knows
him as the one of the great faces of the
BBC yeah and yes he can have free speech
you can't do that at the BBC I know
that's the difference why can't you
because that's that's what it is it's a
taxpayer statement to be clear should be
clear he's not in breach of his contract
he is in breach I'm telling you see God
telling you for 100 100 fact he is not
in breach of anything in his country
he's in breach of there nothing in his
country and he represents nothing in
Gary's 200 appears nothing in his job
yeah and I think you are right there
because you wouldn't be saying it so
definitely as you are but it's a
question of taste and context and good
judgment this was an outrageous thing to
say it was out
so let me stop you there we're going to
have a debate later on the program about
the content of what he said which I took
exception with I don't think there's any
parallel between 1930s German rhetoric
led by Adolf Hitler and that's what
happens when somebody doesn't know
anything about politics understand
Express understand although there have
been some leading members of the Jewish
Community who have said similar things
about this rhetoric involving the small
boat so he's not alone and in fact I
think he was repeating what something
he'd read from a Leading Light of the
Jewish community so we'll come to that
debate a little later I want to bring in
Matthew's side it's a Matthew say let me
ask you this you have presented programs
and podcasts for the BBC right
right
yes yeah but
it's a quick difference checklist to
establish your credentials so you are
you admit to being someone who is
regularly produced and presented BBC
programs and podcasts yes
like many political journalists so hang
on hang on
assembling Mr said I want you to answer
simple question and simple answer you
have presented and produced BBC programs
and podcasts yes
I present a BBC podcast and I'm I'm
proud of the podcast and you're a
freelance but if I can yeah I'm going to
ask you the question in a minute a fact
this is a fact-checking uh exercise uh
and and you're a freelance like linnegan
you're not a BBC employee
that's correct right so how is it you're
allowed to be spewing all sorts of
political opinions all over Twitter
zahawi is sacked you said in 29th of
January this year but the corruption
goes wider and deeper
20th of November 2022 it's been a period
of hugely damaging contradictory
Economic Policy from a single party
trust trash Boris soon actress trace and
brexit keep shape-shifting the most
damning thing Tory back benches have
cheered and wave papers through it no
these are if you're not a tour if you're
not uh well if you're if you're a Tory
reading this you would say you're an
anti-conservative pundit using your
Twitter feed to express strongly held
opinions about government policies you
don't agree with and so I'm my question
I agree it's been a laborious Journey
what is the difference between you and
Gary lineker why do you feel he should
be censored and if he does it again be
fired which I think is your position but
you Matthew Saeed can continue
presenting programs for the BBC and
podcasts and spew away about politics
with no censorship or being fired or are
you offering to fire yourself live on
Piers Morgan uncensored no
may I respond you may now respond
thank you so I think the fundamental
distinction there are many uh political
journalists who I think are rightly
hired by the BBC to bring a trenchant
opinion uh to the airwaves and we are
sold and packaged as people who have
strong political opinions Michael's
distinction I think was the absolutely
critical one there are certain people
who are the voices the faces of the BBC
lineker is much more than a sports
journalist we can see this to a certain
extent by the fact that his comment on a
political policy of the day has become a
dominant story and the thing to bear in
mind is that part of his moral Authority
his cachet his cultural Kudos is because
of the relationship with the BBC the
platform that he has to speak to
millions of people not just on Match of
the day when England plays an
international competition he is the
person who is speaking and
editorializing for 20 sometimes more
million people and I think people who
are paying the license fee are entitled
to expect impartiality from people with
that status okay I sadly uh am a minnow
if you don't mind myself it appears if I
may ask if I may ask you a question you
may just to push you on your position
yeah I agreed with a very great deal of
what you said about free speech I think
there's a great deal of hypocrisy from
those who are criticizing linica now who
would be celebrating him if he had
praised government policy on Asylum but
let me ask you this imagine England are
playing Germany in the final of the
World Cup three o'clock in the afternoon
and people are looking at lineker's feed
because he is a BBC freelancer and half
an hour before kickoff he's not a news
journalist he's not a political
journalist but because of the
association with the BBC he chooses that
moment to make a comparison between the
government labor or conservative and the
Nazi party Are you seriously telling me
that the fact that he is a sports
journalist enables him to say what he
wishes via the BBC platform well my
response would be my original question
to you I don't see any ethical
distinction other than his Fame
which I don't think he should be blamed
for because that's because of his
success and his legacy is one of the
all-time great England Strikers I see no
ethical difference between him and You
and I by the way I like your stuff as
you know I've told you this before I
like your column apart from when you're
hammering me right
um and I like your I like your tweets
when you're not hammering me so to be
clear I I have no problem with what you
do I just see no distinction between a
freelancer like lineker and a freelancer
like you both presenting shows for the
BBC him with perhaps more success which
is why he gets more money and fame which
is not his fault and as a result you
think there's a distinction because it
saves you from having to be exposed to
the same argument and therefore get
censored and maybe fired which seems
very convenient so let's draw the this
but you you have very cleverly not
answered the question that I asked you
the the funnel okay fair enough
to be fair I'll answer you're right I've
actually written a column in the sun
tonight in which I basically answered
this question my bigger problem with
lineker was nothing to do with the
tweets on his personal account which I
don't care about because I don't really
go to going on again for my political
opinions uh I I did object to his
monologue at the start of the Qatar
World Cup because I felt that was the
fusion of sport and we'll play a little
clip of it here there's a bit of that
monolith
ever since FIFA chose Qatar back in 2010
the smallest Nation to have hosted
football's greatest competition has
faced some big questions
from accusations of corruption in the
bidding process to the treatment of
Migrant workers who built the stadiums
where many lost their lives
homosexuality is illegal here
women's rights and freedom of expression
are in the spotlight
also the decision six years ago to
switch the world cup from Summer to
Winter
against that backdrop there's a
tournament to be played one that will be
watched and enjoyed around the world
stick to football say FIFA well we will
for a couple of minutes at least
now I had a problem with that because I
don't think that was appropriate and
I'll say why because there was no such
monologue at the Russia World Cup there
will be no such monologue at the start
of the one in America Canada and Mexico
I can bet my life on it Qatar was
singled out for the one and only
monologue even the China Olympics when
they did that the BBC they didn't do any
monologue about human rights and I felt
that was wrong and I said so at the time
and I said so tonight in my column so in
answer to your point I would say if it
said on air I have a problem with it if
you said on a personal account and he's
a sports presenter I don't have a
problem with it that's where my line is
even if it was half an hour before 20
million people are going to tune in to a
map what I'm trying to get you to
acknowledge peers is the inextricable
link between lineker's moral Authority I
mean we would not be discussing any
other footballer making a claim about
politics I mean if others go to Gary
World Cup
that is conferred by the BBC yeah but I
don't go to Gary didn't give a moral
Authority for goodness sake any more
than you'd come to me for it would you
bring in he's pretty he's the face of
the BBC it's a taxpayer-funded impartial
Hugh Edwards who reads the news it makes
no difference together they're not no
they are they're absolutely in together
the editorial guidelines make that
Crystal Clear they're all in it together
you're drawing a distinction about his
contract that's irrelevant he's relevant
it's completely irrelevant he represents
it's actually it's the reason he's not
being censored he represents the BB
this is about the BBC I believe
passionately
in free speech Nations speak peace unto
Nation all of you want himself no it's
about trust we're talking about the BBC
here and Gary lineker but the BBC first
the BBC was built on trust it took
decades around the world and it can be
lost very very quickly and the most
important part of that trust is
impartiality not neutrality that's a
completely different thing but being
impartial and if that is undermined by
episodes like this people will just say
well that's the BBC again spouting off
this way or that way
okay fine so are you shaftable with
Matthew sahib BBC presenter of a number
of programs and podcasts making
political points on Twitter yes or no I
agree yes you are well they used to
totally she's also brought it into
distribute sorry I'm sorry
the organization are you comfortable
with Matthew
he's also brought the organization into
distribute everybody's talking about it
and that's very bad luck only in this
review to those who don't agree with him
came out tomorrow and said you know what
this small boat's policy is fantastic
send them all back home you would be
straight out there going Knight turns
for Gary little again
because I've got integrity and he's
completely wrong and you're wrong three
one I think has got a lot of integrity
and by the way he's a lot of balls he
stood by his stood by his position today
he was wrong they all agree lineker has
to go but Matthew say he can carry on
presenting BBC programs because he's an
experience
as long as we've all reached a point of
consensus I think I've won my argument
gentlemen
very much indeed